every business has a different model of
how they make money today we're going to
talk about the ten different business
models of how to build your business
around all right before I get into it if
you haven't yet subscribed to the
channel please do so so let's get right
into these are ten different business
models of how to generate revenue
there's many ways of doing it but these
are ten different models the first one
is you give the product away for free a
lot of times people wonder why are they
giving away the product for free because
they make the money on the back end of
advertising example YouTube many
companies do this this is one of the
models the second model is the freemium
model with the pay for upgrade LinkedIn
is free but if you want to upgrade you
got to go and subscribe to a certain
cost that they have right it's an
upgrade 24.95 49.99 ninety nine ninety
five but you start up as a freemium so
business model number three is pricing
based on average value to customer
meaning so you got you got five
different customers right and maybe
health insurance it may be auto
insurance somebody may be a great driver
they don't have any issue somebody may
be a terrible driver they have a lot of
issues they average that out and come up
with a price point that's average to the
customer and some may be paying a little
bit higher some may be paying a little
bit less but it is what it is like the
health insurance when it came out
recently they said well why am i paying
so much insurance when I'm younger and
I'm healthy I don't have any issues
you're kind of paying for the insurance
or the people that are not healthy
but they're getting it so it's the
average cost for the product they're
selling fork model its price based on
product cost plus margin this is
traditional you buy these pants for
twenty dollars you sell them for thirty
dollars you buy this you know whatever
product you get for fifteen bucks you
sell it for 40 bucks right number five
is price with recurring low subscription
payment hence Netflix it's a very common
model today people say Netflix $7.99 999
1290 that's not a lot of money times 850
million customers it's a lot of money
number six is very basic tiered pricing
based on volume so real estate how much
you buy how much is your volume the more
you buy the less we charge you you know
if you're if I'm getting a commission
contract with an insurance company if
you sell this much policies will give
you this much but if you sell more will
give you more so it's all volume based
the more you do the more leverage you
have for an
Oshin the more you do the more the less
the cost is going to be to the customer
because you're banking on volume number
seven is revenue as a percentage of
every transaction Commission okay that's
a commission that they're doing the
revenue comes from a commission base
that they're paying out number eight low
product price but support it's extra
this is everywhere the product isn't
that much but you want the extra support
here's $99 per year or 999 dollars all
that stuff that additional that they
tagged on number nine low entry price
with priced features additional so
you're buying a car this car right here
I just bought a car and it's being
delivered right now
but if you want to add this and if you
want to add this and if you get this
it's all the additional add-ons that you
have right that's the additional adults
and last but not least number ten is
very simple low price but money is made
based on disposable so I sell this razor
stick and I sell it to you for 10 bucks
but I know I you got to come and buy the
razors every time you don't shave it
because it goes from green to white you
gotta buy I'm making my money on
disposable it's a very very big Procter
& Gamble type of a business model but
it's very effective again
it's all about how you want to set up
your business model to generate revenue
there's many different ways of doing it
these are ten of the ways to do it if
you want the PDF today either text me on
three one zero three four zero one one
three two and text me and say business
models and we'll text you back the link
to the PDF where you can print out and
kind of see what kind of a business
model you want to create and if you're
not in this state you still want to get
the PDF to this click on a link below in
the description go subscribe to my
newsletter we'll also send you the PDF
to this I got two other videos I want
you to watch that have to do with this
topic one of the videos is size versus
positioning you want to go on the
marketplace and compete what what do you
want to compete with who do you want to
compete with how do you want to
differentiate yourself to go up against
the bigger companies that's what this
video is about and the other video is
for you that's watching the same I'm an
employee right now and I'm thinking
about becoming an entrepreneur or I'm an
employee right now I'm thinking about
becoming an entrepreneur within my
company but I want to get better out and
see what I could do this video is titled
how to become an entrepreneur so if you
want size versus position click on this
how to become an entrepreneur click on
this video over here and again if you
haven't subscribed to the channel please
do so thanks for watching everybody
take care bye bye
you